dealing with this pandemic has always
been an exercise in managing risk
throughout we have been adamant that the
education of children
is an absolute priority and that keeping
schools open is uppermost in all of our
plans
the magnificent efforts of all the
leaders
teachers and staff in all of our schools
and colleges
have ensured that settings are as safe
and covered secure
as possible but we must always act
swiftly when circumstances change
the evidence about the new covid variant
and rising infection
rates have required some immediate
adjustment to our plans for the new term
this is of course a rapidly shifting
situation
but some things remain constant
we continue to act to preserve lives
and safeguard the national health
service
and we continue to protect education
by putting children first
above all our response is proportionate
to the risk at hand
and makes every use of a contingency
framework
that we put in place earlier this year
the latest study we have from public
health england
is that covered infections among
children
are triggered by changes in
the community rate the study
also says that the wider impact of
school
closures on children's development would
be significant
i'm quite clear that we must continue to
do all we can
to keep children in school
taking all these factors into account
means that
we have had to make a number of changes
for the new term
in order to help with breaking chains of
transmission
and to assist with keeping all of our
children
and our education settings as safe as we
can
the fact that we have managed to do this
so successfully throughout the
entire pandemic is due to the incredible
dedication
of all our teachers leaders and support
staff and i know that the house will
join me
once more in thanking them for
everything that they continue to do
to keep children learning as safely as
possible
accordingly we'll be opening the
majority of primary schools as planned
on monday the 4th
of january we know how vitally important
it is for younger children to be in
school for their education
well-being being and wider development
in a small number of areas where the
infection rates are highest
we will implement our existing
contingency framework
such as only vulnerable children and
children of critical workers will attend
face to face
we will publish this list of areas today
on the gov dot
uk website i'd like to emphasize that
this
is being used only as a last resort
this is not all tier four areas and that
the majority
the overwhelming majority of primary
schools will open
as planned on monday
the areas will also be reviewed
regularly that so schools can
reopen at the very earliest moment
ongoing testing for primary school staff
will follow later in january and we
will be working to establish an
ambitious testing program
helping to break chains of transmission
and reducing the need
for self-isolation where students and
staff test
negative for the virus
we have already announced our intention
for a staggered return to education for
this term
for secondary age pupils and those in
colleges
because the covid infection rate is
particularly high
among this age group we are going to
allow
more time so that every school and
college is able to fully
roll out testing for all of its pupils
and and staff i would like to thank
school leaders and staff for all of
their ongoing work in preparing this
this kind of mass testing will help
protect not just children
and young people will benefit everyone
in the community it will break
those chains of transmission there's a
making infection rate shoot up
this in turn will make it safer for more
children to physically return to school
all pupils in exam years are to return
during the week beginning the 11th of
january
with all secondary school and college
students returning full-time
on the 18th of january during the first
week of term on or after the 4th of
january secondary schools and colleges
will prepare to test as many staff and
students
as possible and will only be open to
vulnerable children and for children of
key workers
the 1500 military personnel committed to
supporting schools and colleges
will remain on task providing virtual
training and advice on establishing the
testing process
with teams on standby to provide
in-person support
if required by schools
testing will then begin the following
week in earnest
with those who are in exam years at the
head of the queue
this is in preparation for the full
return of all pupils in
all year groups on the 18th of january
in most areas
to allow this focus on establishing
testing throughout the first week of
term
exam year groups will continue to have
lessons remotely
in line with what they would receive in
class
and only vulnerable children and
children of critical workers
will have face-to-face teaching as
with primary schools we'll be applying
our existing
existing contingency framework for
education in areas of the country
with very high rates of covid infection
or
transmission of the virus this will
require secondary schools and colleges
to offer face-to-face education
to only exam years vulnerable children
and children of critical workers
with remote education being given to all
of the students
if they are in one of those contingency
framework
areas we're also asking universities to
reduce the number of students who return
to campus at the start of january
prioritizing students who require
practical learning
to gain their professional
qualifications all university
students should be offered two rapid
tests
on return in order to reduce the chance
of spread of covid